well we've come a long ways in the year
2000 the world wasn't focused on this
problem we didn't have science working
on it we didn't have funds going after
it
and since that time we've gone from a
million children near dying now to about
four hundred thousand so that's still
tragic we should get it down even more
but amazing what we've done and we have
a pipeline of innovations whether it's
drugs or new insecticides that are
coming along so even as the mosquito
evolves away from being susceptible we
come in with I mean what did what is the
vulnerability well why are these
mosquitoes still getting through well
anytime you use the same insecticide
over a period of time it puts pressure
on the mosquitoes to evolve around it
and you know originally DDT worked well
the mosquitoes have alter on that this
generation is called pyrethroid we
continued to use it because we've got
the cost down a lot until we see the
resistance and I I just showed the new
bed net that has a novel insecticide
actually two on the same net that NETL
cost a little bit more but given the
resistance we need to get that out there
as fast as we can so you know we're
being smart we're using a lot of
modeling to predict what the best tools
are and in the long run we can beat it
but this is a gonna take decades to
fully finish and the preventative things
like nets and vaccinations and also the
palliative things for people who
affected with it do all the people who
need it have access to those now are
getting the bed nets out to the most
rural areas there's always a challenge
if you have a good primary healthcare
system then that's the vehicle we use
but if you get to say Democratic
Republic of Congo oh it's hard we did
actually succeed in getting the nets out
to a lot of areas we go out and do
surveillance to see okay where there's
still a lot of cases and so we've got a
map now that's actually pretty precise
down to a fine resolution and it shows
us there's still hot spots so no it's
never easy to get
these things out to every child in the
world and what about the smart solutions
things like genetic manipulation where
are we on that in the lab there's a
technique called CRISPR that can change
the mosquito DNA in a way that either
the population goes down a lot or it
doesn't carry this parasite and you know
we're talking through with the African
countries what sort of tests trials do
we need to do before that gets added to
the arsenal so it'll take a number of
years to get all those country approvals
but the potential there to reduce the
mosquito population and therefore
locally get rid of the disease makes it
a very promising addition I mean we're
talking about people in poor countries
primarily in Africa what is the
technology that you developed at
Microsoft and and others what is that
coming in this fight against malaria
well the digital tools you know they let
researchers work together they let
people do simulations to decide what the
mix of tools is is best you know getting
saving their job from malaria is more
basic than you know computing so we're
going to the toughest places in the
world to say okay
let's get a bed mat out there let's get
this kid to grow up in a healthy way you
know not have the cerebral malaria that
permanently damages these kids cognitive
abilities you've given a lot of money
taxpayers also give a lot of money a lot
of argument about that do you think it's
right that countries like Britain which
still have many poor people should be
assisting these sort of programs well I
think if you take one and a half percent
of your budget and say okay for the
poorest of the world you know which is
you know 20 times as many people have
here if you're having you know dramatic
impact where you're saving lives for a
very small amount of money and you're
transforming those societies so over
time they can be stable they can be
self-sufficient you know their
population growth goes down so that
issues like the environment and
stability and
pandemics are easier to do it I think to
a very smart investment
you know the 98.5 percent of the money
you know should all be spent here and
you know the amount you're willing to
spend per person is you know way over a
hundred times but to have that
one-and-a-half percent
I I think it's brilliant and that money
you know I've chosen to spend money on
these things right along we did we're
picking things we're getting smarter all
the time I wish everybody could go out
and see it because they'd be proud what
about the British contribution I mean
you've written today in the newspapers
about the Commonwealth mean lot of
people might be surprised to see an
American coming to a sort of post
British Imperial event well the
Commonwealth is a pretty good construct
because you've got countries like Canada
and Australia in the UK that are helping
these other countries it's not just a
region you've got every level of income
in the Commonwealth over half the people
who are susceptible to malaria over 90%
of Commonwealth citizens are at risk of
getting malaria so we were super pleased
that the Commonwealth organisers said
okay on the side we're gonna have
top-level people here you can bring
visibility to the need to double down
and and move ahead on this disease so
it's been a great collaboration to do it
in connection with the column I mean you
want a find it breaks it how'd you find
Britain now that we are leaving the
European Union you think we are still as
internationalists as we used to be well
the great scientists are here you know
working out exactly how the R&D money's
gonna work and you know scientists
coming from other countries no doubt in
the UK is gonna be at the forefront of a
lot of these medical science issues
whether it's dementia malaria we've got
over a billion dollars of grants here in
the UK funding science because it's
incredible science do you think you were
perhaps I have a clue me about breaks it
you know I I'm not a voter in the UK so
but you didn't say you didn't think it
looked like a great idea
no that was my my view and you know you
don't get to
try the UK with brexit without braixen
compare the two so you know now will and
will take advantage of the great
capabilities here we'll make sure we're
being pragmatic about how things are
changing you know we're we're very
committed to partner with the UK you
used to be the richest man in the world
I think in now the second richest man
the world commiserations on that I mean
what why did you decide with your wife
and your foundation to devote so much of
your fortune to philanthropy well the
you know the money we have should go
back to society to have the greatest
possible impact and funding innovation
funding work in the poorest countries of
the world I think and we need more
people to get engaged in that it's very
exciting when we can make progress like
we have you know a lot of the skills of
building partnerships funding science
that I developed a Microsoft I'm getting
to use in my work at the foundation and
you know it's not like we're gonna spend
the money on ourselves or that we think
it'd be a favor to create some you know
dynastic approach to this fortune it
will be spent on these issues I mean did
reason why I'm asking that is because
obviously it's not what every
billionaire does with it with their
money so there must be something
different or maybe something they ought
to be doing well more of the very
wealthy are engaging in philanthropy
it's a growing thing we have a group
called The Giving Pledge of the people
who've been very successful we're
committed to giving the majority of
their wealth we have quite a few about
ten here in the UK after the u.s. it's
the country that's got the most
committed to this Giving Pledge so
helping people spend that money well
enjoy spending that money and and set an
example to draw all of the wealthy and
that's another thing I think is helpful
and I enjoy doing and do you think
you're the next generation if you like
that we call them the Fang that we quite
often do you think they are living up to
their social responsibilities in the
same way well it's actually impressive
that some of those leaders at a younger
age than I did are getting involved in
in philanthropy and so yes the tech
industry most the people are successful
there I think will be really strong
philanthropists we see that worldwide is
a sector that you know doesn't think
that you know they're gonna pass it
along so they want it to go back and
help reduce inequity what about the
downside I mean I guess as these
technologies are being developed people
didn't see the adverse consequences
which with Facebook and other things I
see now that would be a correct
assumption with it oh it's true
cars ended up you know killing people
electricity ended up electrocuting
people almost nothing we've ever
invented is a hundred percent beneficial
and figuring out okay how do you deal
with the safety issues and how do you do
with the licensing issues and you know
we're seeing as this technology becomes
so pervasive even a key tool of
communication there's a lot of
regulatory issues that are having to be
developed I mean you think government
needs to get involved more I mean what
if they came to you and said oh you're
one of the creators of the Internet what
needs to be done to regulate it now and
make it a better and safer place well
the privacy laws
Europe's got a new set of regulations
those who are you know companies are
gonna adhere to those and I'm sure
they'll have to evolve but it's a it's a
good first step to put consumers in
control and you know the governments
have have the ability to set the rules
and make sure that the negative effects
are minimized
we need governments we can't just do it
all online I'm certainly a huge believer
in government whether it's
infrastructure education and justice you
know for all the imperfections of the
rich world governments when I'm in
Africa I dream that we'd have anything
like that effect whatever we don't from
well the US government's a well-run
government you know and we can always
you know exercise our democratic voices
trying to make it better okay thank you